well hey there thank you all for being
here and an especially warm welcome if
this is your first time with us
Adventist or otherwise so we are back
with another open discussion this time
we're going to be listening to two
varying perspectives on the nature of
death we'll probably end up getting into
the nature of the Soul some I would
imagine I will note that based on how
the last open discussion went moving
forward these will be a lot more
structured and formalized to keep that
from happening
again so the noral question of the
night does the bible teach that death is
a sleep does the bible teach that death
is asleep an important topic so I'm
looking forward to the discussion but
first before getting into it if you like
what we are doing here and you want to
partner with us you can do so at
answering adventism tocom donate our
mission is to equip as many Christians
as possible to reach as many Seventh
Adventist is possible with the true
Christ and his gospel and it is through
the support of our partners that we are
able to do just that that so A major
major thank you to all of our partners
and YouTube
members taking the affirmative this
evening is Matt Mara Matt's been here
before um and we're excited to have him
back Matt first came to Jesus when he
was just 21 years of age a former punk
rocker at the time he found in Jesus all
the help he needed he became a Bible
teacher and a preacher of the Gospel to
many lands including Africa Indonesia
Malaysia Thailand and Singapore he has a
deep passion for sharing the gospel and
God's love through the truths in the
Bible he holds a bachelor's degree from
Andrews University and Wasa Hills
College he resides in Highland Mills New
York with his beautiful wife Michaela
and children Jacob and
Julia and then taking the negative side
this evening is Joe hesm Joe has also
been with us before just not in this
format he is a Roman Catholic apologist
at Catholic answers and he is the host
of the Shameless popery podcast he has a
law degree from Georgetown University
Law Center in Washington DC a Philosophy
degree from Kendrick Glennon seminary in
St Louis and a theology degree from the
pontifical University of St Thomas
aquinus in Rome he enjoys speaking and
debating on a wide range of issues
including the papacy the beliefs of the
earliest Christians the Eucharist and
sacramental Theology and
pro-life
issues gentlemen thank you so much for
giving us some of your time let me get
you unmuted here thank you for being
here
thank you for having us thanks for
having us absolutely so a quick rundown
for the audience to let everyone know
the agenda for the
night each interlocutor will have an8
minute un uninterrupted introduction to
make their case this will be followed by
80 minutes of back and forth
cross-examination and questioning broken
down into 20 minut uh 20 minute
increments of control time the
individual that has control time can
control the conversation by way of
asking questions but we obviously want
the person being asked to be able to
answer the question so it'll be 20
minutes of asking and then it'll reverse
20 minutes of asking and then they'll do
that same thing again so both
individuals will get 40 minutes each of
control time we want to have a good
rigorous discussion tonight where two
positions are both presented and
examined and then we will close the
night off with each individual being
given an eight minute uninterrupted
closing to share their final thoughts I
will be functioning as a neutral
moderator facilitating the dialogue and
making sure we stay on subject if either
individual needs scripture brought up
just ask and I will get that brought up
so you don't need to be distracted with
any of that if we do happen to get off
track which is understandable in these
discussions I will step in and get us
back on track gentlemen final point in
the past we have used a buzzer to
indicate when uh there's one minute left
as well as when the time is up the
problem is if a person is talking the
buzzer sound tends to be drowned out so
no one hears it and ends up uh just
continuing to go along so I will Simply
Be verbalizing when you have one minute
left and when the time is up if you are
in the middle of a thought when time is
up feel free to finish the thought any
questions
nope all right we discussed backstage
and Matt will be starting and kicking us
off your time will begin sir when you
begin
speaking great well thank you uh miles
again for hosting this discussion uh
welcome everybody again my name is Matt
Mara tonight I'll be speaking on what
the Bible says about death you can learn
a little bit more on my position by
going to www.adventuresinvisibility.com
his virgin birth uh the physical
resurrection of the Dead we do differ on
what is the state of the dead before
that Resurrection before that bodily
Resurrection so the question tonight
does the bible teach that the death is a
sleep my position is in the affirmative
that the Bible
consistently uh teaches that death and
describes death as a state analogous to
sleep in which the dead are unconscious
and awaiting Resurrection so in support
of my position I'll be examining uh key
biblical key biblical text number one
number two uh addressing any
counterarguments that are commonly
raised and number three demonstrating
the theological coherence of this view
within the broader biblical narrative so
as far as key biblical texts uh the
metaphor of death as asleep is not
incidental in scripture it's actually
both pervasive and intentional uh
considering a few examples we can turn
um at random here in the Old Testament
as a witness to Daniel
12:2 where we read and many of those
those who sleep in the dust of the Earth
shall awake I'm not sure if miles you
want me to wait for you to bring it up
but I'll just keep going um Daniel 12:2
many of those who sleep in the dust of
the Earth shall awake some to
everlasting life and some to shame and
everlasting contempt the use here of
sleep clearly refers to the state of the
dead and the imagery is tied to the hope
of resurrection and in the context
that's where it is likewise the Psalms
also affirm the unconscious state of the
Dead in psalm
146 and
verse4 it says Psalm 146:4 it says when
his breath departs he returns to the
Earth on that very day his plans perish
this again supports the idea that the
dead are not active or conscious Psalm
13:3 consider and answer me oh Lord my
God light up my eyes lest I sleep the
sleep of
death okay so these are some Old
Testament Witnesses the new test
confirms as well uh and continues this
theme Jesus himself refers to death as
sleep in John 11: 11-14 when speaking of
Lazarus he says our friend Lazarus has
fallen asleep but I go to awaken him
when the disciples misunderstood what
Jesus was saying he clarifies that he is
speaking of lazarus's death Paul
frequently uses the term sleep for death
as well for example 1 Thessalonians 4:
13- 14 he writes but we do not want you
to be uninformed Brothers about those
who are asleep that you may not grieve
as others do who have no hope for since
we believe that Jesus died and rose
again even so through Jesus God will
bring with him those who have fallen
asleep this language is not metaphorical
in the sense of minimizing death but
rather to reflect the hope of
Resurrection all right so Point number
two I'm going to address a little bit on
some counter arguments one common
objection is a passage uh that has
popularized the immortality of the Soul
um or that the soul uh proceeds after
death uh is Luke 16: 19-31 the story of
the rich man and Lazarus describes
conscious uh activity uh after death or
so it seems this is a parable however
not a doctrinal teaching on the
intermediate State uh Parables use vivid
imagery to convey moral or theological
truths without necess necessarily
providing uh a little account of events
and I'm sure we'll be discussing that
further additionally passages like
Philippians 1:23 and second Corinthians
58 where Paul expresses a desire to be
with Christ these are often cited as
evidence of an immediate Consciousness
after death however these verses can be
understood in light of Paul's esic hope
meaning his focus on being with Christ
at the resurrection not at an interim
State okay number three theological
coherence uh the view that death is
asleep aligned seamlessly with the
overarching biblical Narrative of
Resurrection it's very very closely tied
which is why if you go to adventist.org
uh hyen uhde hyen and uh hyphen
Resurrection they're closely linked
together the consistent hope presented
in scripture is not of disembodied souls
in a conscious in intermediate state but
of bodily Resurrection at Christ's
return for example 1 Corinthians 15: 22
and 23 Paul and emphasizes that the
resurrection is the Cornerstone of the
Christian hope he writes for as in Adam
all die so also in Christ shall all be
made alive but each in his own order
okay so when will all be made alive
Christ the first fruits then at his
coming those who belong to Christ this
future orientation makes little sense
obviously if the dead are already
conscious and experiencing their final
punishment or reward so conclusion the
Bible's consistent use of sleep as a
metaphor for death reflects the
unconscious state of the dead as they
await the resurrection this view is
rooted in both the Old and New
Testaments withstands scrutiny against
common objections and harmonizes with
the biblical Narrative of redemption
through Resurrection um I look forward
to hearing Joe's perspective on this and
engaging in further in discussion as I
said I'm sure there'll be some text that
we'll be repeating thank you you got two
minutes left are you good uh yeah I'm
good I have some other things I'll go
through as we as we
discuss all right thank you so much for
that Matt Joe the same courtesy will be
extended to you your time will begin
when you begin talking sir wonderful
well I mean let me again uh start off by
saying thank you to you miles for
hosting and for thinking of me for this
debate uh and Matt for taking the
trouble to advance the Adventist
Viewpoint particularly on a platform
called answering adventism I respect
that a lot it's it's bold it's I'm I'm a
fan uh
although I suspect we're going to
disagree more than we agree this evening
it is certainly My Hope for all watching
and all involved this can be done with
the spirit of Christian charity and the
desire that maybe all of us uh have
something to learn or appreciate more on
the topic of the Soul on the topic of
the afterlife on the topic of
resurrection and of life with Christ
which are hopefully near and dear to the
hearts of of everyone here and everyone
watching so if I may I'll just sketch
out the 20,000 view uh for the negative
side and then show some of its
implications uh first it's necessary to
say a little bit what we mean by soul
and uh I would say this you are uh not
your soul you are not your body you are
the union of body and soul you have
different parts to your body so to your
person excuse me so describing your
person is just your body or just your
soul which are common errors that even
Christians fall into would be like
describing water as just hydrogen or
just oxygen it's a mistake and it's a
mistake that we see corrected in the
biblical accounts and in fact I would
suggest that you see this in increasing
clarity as you move throughout the Old
Testament and then as you move from the
Old Testament to the New Testament one
of the basic principles in interpreting
scripture is that there's this idea of
what sometimes called progressive
revelation and this is spoken to at the
beginning of the epistle to the Hebrews
that in many and various ways God spoke
to us by the prophets and now he's
spoken to us by the Sun so when you're
getting the especially in the Torah the
first five books of the Bible you're
getting things that are true but you're
not getting the full story if you were
you wouldn't get any other books after
that right and so we want to take
everything we're seeing from Genesis
forward but build upon what we've
already learned and be willing to learn
new information so as we're going to see
this you'll see things for instance the
view of the afterlife becomes clearer as
we move through the Old Testament
and becomes a lot clear as we get into
the New Testament that's also true uh
when we're talking about the state of
the soul and so soul and body you are
the union of these two things and this
is certainly how scripture speaks again
especially in the New Testament to give
you an example Jesus in Matthew 10 verse
28 says do not fear Those Who Kill the
body but cannot kill the soul rather
fear Him who can destroy both body and
soul in hell and uh it is sometimes
claimed including by the Adventist
website including actually at the spot
that Matt referenced adventist.org and
then all the rest of the stuff I don't
remember it off hand uh it's claimed
that this is like a third Century uh
like introduction from paganism and that
is just flatly not true the idea of
Spiritual Beings is certainly found uh
from Genesis onwards you have Spirits
you have the Holy Spirit you have uh
Angels you have demons you demons are
even described as unclean spirits so the
idea that there are a spiritually we
would say in technical terms it's called
the spiritually subsistent being where
it is something that exists in a
spiritual way apart from a body is
purely biblical the question is simply
whether that's true of the human soul if
the human soul behaves like other
spirits and there is plenty of evidence
that it does and we got one uh bit
towards that in Matthew 1028 with this
reference to the death of the soul in
Hell notice also that Christ
distinguishes two things one he's
distinguishing between body and soul but
two he's distinguishing between the
death of the body and the death of the
soul and if you pay careful attention
you'll find that kind of language used
all throughout scripture there are
several different places uh referring to
spiritual death so to give if I may just
a few examples of that uh in James
chapter 5 verse 19 my brethren If anyone
among you wanders from the truth and
someone brings him back let him know
that whoever brings a sinner from the
err of his way will save his soul from
Death now the implication there is not
the person's about to kill themselves
the belief there is that they're cutting
themselves off from spiritual life
because their soul not their body is
going astray their soul not their body
is incurring spiritual death and this by
the way makes complete sense of the
biblical data to give just one Old
Testament example in Genesis chapter 3
when the serpent tempts Adam and Eve the
remember the the warning of God is that
if they eat of the fruit of the
knowledge of Good and Evil on that day
they will surely die and yet they eat
the fruit and they don't biologically
die this is instead a reference to
spiritual death now to be sure mortality
in a physical sense comes into the world
but they don't actually die that day so
if we don't want to say that Satan was
right and that God was wrong it seems we
have to acknowledge that they did die in
some sense on the day that they rebelled
from God but not obviously in a
corporeal sense of death now this
distinction between corporeal and
spiritual death is found as I said
throughout scripture it's why for
instance in 1 John 516 to17 John can say
that there is sin which is Mortal
meaning deadly and then he can say in
the next verse in verse 17 all
wrongdoing is sin but there is sin which
is not mortal which is not deadly again
the idea there is not that you're going
to physically die if you Rebel from God
the idea there is that you're going to
spiritually die and it would be a a
strange permutation of the text to read
it as corporeal death and if that's not
enough look to the fact that St Paul
talking about Eucharistic discipline in
1 Corinthians 11 warns them in verse 29
anyone who eats and drinks without
Discerning the body eats and drinks
judgment upon himself that is why many
of you are weak and ill and some have
died so
obviously the people reading First
Corinthians who Paul is describing as
weak ill and even dead are not
physically dead like unless you're
saying you know he he wrote first
Corinthians to those who had already
died biologically then you would
seemingly have to say there is this
clear biblical distinction between
bodily and spiritual death I've I've
spent a lot on that but I think it's an
important principle uh to to lay out now
turning from there to uh the New
Testament parable of Lazarus and the
rich man if you want to call it a
parable there's a question about whether
it's a parable or a description for our
purposes it doesn't matter I'd say two
things number one this depicts something
that clearly is at odds with Adventist
theology which is why they have to say
oh it's just like vivid imagery if one
minute left thank you if Jesus is
presenting an accurate vision of the
afterlife an accurate vision of death in
his Parable then adventism is wrong and
the resolution should be negated because
what we find there is a few things that
are are particularly important in Luke
16:23 we're told the rich man died and
was buried and in Hades being in torment
he lifted up his eyes and saw Abraham
far off and Lazarus in his bosom so
where was the rich man well bodily he
was asleep in the grave spiritually he
was very much not asleep and we see him
having a conversation with Abraham
likewise we could say where is Lazarus
you know you already heard Matt mention
that in John 11 Jesus describes Lazarus
as bodily or as asleep we would say all
of those sleeping images tied to death
are referring to bodily sleep that
spiritually something quite different is
depicted as going on which again in Luke
16 you get this conversation happening
time okay so I think that it gives us
enough of the starting place and we can
kind of let the conversation develop
from there thank you
gentlemen all right thank you both for
that we are now going to be
transitioning into our 80 minute
cross-examination period which just to
remind people will be broken up into
four 20 minute segments each of the
interlocutors receiving 40 minutes of
control time control time is for you to
lead the discussion by asking questions
and examining just so the audience
understands the person controlling the
time and asking questions can do exactly
that they can control their time as they
see fit if they want to move on to a new
question because time is running out and
they want to get through their questions
they are free to do so Matt the control
time will start with you again the time
we'll start once you ask your first
question
sir okay thank you um question Joe uh
you spoke about the uh you not a soul
you are a union of soul and body so do
you also affirm or believe that the soul
is naturally
Immortal the soul is naturally
Everlasting because it doesn't have the
conditions of mortality that bodies do
so bodies break down there's nothing
like that the
soul okay um so when you say Everlasting
can you break that down a little bit
more like do you mean so in in technical
terms there's a difference between
Everlasting and eternal because Eternal
properly speaking is without beginning
or end and we don't believe in like the
pre-existence of souls like Mormons do
so we we believe that the soul has a
beginning but not a natural end you
believe the right has a beginning but
doesn't have an end the soul doesn't
have a natural end like it's not outside
of the power God that he could
annihilate a soul we don't think that
does happen but it's in the nature of
the body you see you know all the
effects of entropy and age and
everything else those things aren't true
at the level of the
Soul so how does your understanding of a
soul not having an end um does like what
does that mean like does that mean it
won't cease to exist does it mean it
won't die what does that exactly mean
when you say it doesn't have an end it
won't cease to exist it won't be
annihilated I mean again it could be
annihilated by a special Act of God we
don't believe that does happen but it's
not outside for purposes of our
conversation of the nature of the soul
the question of would God choose to
annihilate a soul that would not have
died naturally uh is a a separate
question I just want to make sure that
distinction is being made very clearly
so if you think about the nature of
Angels and Demons Angels and Demons
aren't getting old they're not just like
dying of old age they aren't getting
cancer they're not none of the things
that can kill uh a person bodily impact
Spiritual Beings that's not the way
Spiritual Beings operate so in as much
as you have a spiritual component to
your being that component of your being
endures now what that endurance looks
like is the whole question of Salvation
like is this an eternity with God in
what we would call eternal life or is
this an eternity a part from God which
we would call Eternal
death okay um so question for you is
okay thank you for that answer um it's
it's still a little bit ambiguous in
terms of the so what would be the answer
to the question is what kind of death is
the wages of sin spoken of in Romans 6
verse 23 which by the way it's actually
go ahead Contra yeah contrasted with
eternal life so what kind of how how
would you describe that as far as um how
would your understanding of death be in
that situation yeah there's like a
three-fold sense of that because you
have the the wages of sin if you go back
and think about what we're talking about
here the original Rebellion from God
that incurs spiritual death that it cuts
off proper relationship with God Adam
and Eve are not enjoying heaven but they
are en enjoying a sort of paradisal
relationship in fact even the word
Paradise for w Garden has obvious
reference to the Garden of Eden so
they're enjoying Paradise but they
aren't enjoying what we would call the
full glorification like there is still
something more that they can desire in
terms of the the
degree of their Union with God and
they're being transformed into
godlikeness this is why uh the devil is
able to tempt them with that in Genesis
3 that he wants them to desire to be
like God but he wants them to try to get
it on their own terms so that spiritual
life and death framework is already at
at issue here so they're seeking uh a
sort of if you want a spiritual
elevation or glorification and instead
incur a spiritual death they they cut
themselves off from Eden they're cast
out they have suffering they have all of
those effects from it they're
spiritually wounded in their
relationship with God there's a whole
realm of what we would call Original Sin
additionally there's bodily death that
mortality enters into the world with
this and then on a tertiary level
there's also the corruption that St Paul
speaks about when he talks about all
creation groaning in agony there's a
sense in which the entire material
Cosmos in some mysterious sense suffers
as a result of original sin
okay so okay I mean that's that's all
right so you gave three three levels to
the word death in terms of the context
of the wages of sin um so right because
like we we would see original sin is is
a radical Act of rebellion like when
Adam and Eve rebell from God if you even
you just read Genesis 3 and say what
gets corrupted and it's like well it's
man's relationship with God it's Adam
and Eve's relationship with each other
it's their relationship with the natural
Cosmos and we would say even further you
could talk about the relationship with
oneself that all of the the levels of
interior relationship are corrupted
they're not totally abolished they're
not totally destroyed but they're
they're warped and damaged in a pretty
fundamental
way so is Romans 623 then since we're on
that and it's up on the screen um so is
that speaking of spiritual
death 23 yeah that the wages of sin is
not just that you bodily die uh but you
actually are eternally cut off from God
that is the the natural consequence of
so spiritual death is being eternally
cut off from God yeah and I mean in an
approximate sense spiritual death is not
having the life of God within your soul
we okay um the the because I'm just
saying the text is contrasting eternal
life with uh with death therefore the
death is you know we can obviously say
Eternal death but you're saying
spiritual death is eternal death or spir
I'm sorry I'm just kind of
so when we're talking about eternal life
and eternal death this is one area where
I know Catholics are going to part
company from some camps of Protestants
we would say that it is possible to
leave eternal life and likewise to leave
Eternal death by becoming saved so but
it is that it is in reference to that
now once someone dies whether they're in
a state of eternal life or death is
fixed it's permanent but prior to that
point someone can turn back they can you
know second Peter 2 talks about those
who've been Ransom by Christ going back
to their sins they went from a place of
spiritual death to a place of spiritual
life and then back again so we would say
you can move from a place of spiritual
death to life but it is a a reference to
the relationship of the soul to God
because you are made for Eternal
happiness with God and nothing apart
from God will ever satisfy your soul and
so to have everything but God is to have
nothing okay um just quick thing is is
uh if eternal life right is more than
spiritual right then wouldn't death also
be more than
spiritual um yeah I mean like I said
death in the sense of original sin
includes both bodily death and spiritual
death okay um now you referred to you're
you're getting the um I think you picked
up the idea of spiritual death you
referred to back in the garden right
Genesis uh chapter 2 and chapter 3 and
uh how do you align your idea now I
don't disagree that there was a
spiritual death but I don't believe it
was merely speaking of spiritual death
um okay so the the reason I'm bringing
this up is that I believe the death that
uh we're reading here in context if you
go to Genesis chapter 3 verse 22-
24 uh is related to them living
forever I think that is that is probably
one of the meanings of it um there like
the way the early chapters of Genesis us
age where you see this Progressive
shortening of Ages As you move through
seems to be speaking at least in some
sense literally or metaphorically uh to
kind of the effects of of sin and
Rebellion from God making life worse on
both a bodily and spiritual
level like understand I'm not suggesting
sin only harms you spiritually it harms
you bodily as well so it's it's not an
either or like you're not going to get
me to say sin only hurts you spirit and
not bodily it's not the case like if you
do hard drugs and you say does that hurt
you spiritually or bodily the answer is
going to be yes
both okay um
so all right so uh how do you define
then uh according to how you define your
theological position on the on the on
the soul right how does your definition
align or differ with the biblical
language About Soul meaning nefesh andsy
so nefes and psyche are used in a
variety of ways like you don't want to
build a theology just from a a
concordance particularly when you're
looking at several different centuries
and different authors and the way they
use words like think about even the way
we use soul in English like if I'm
listening to Soul music or if I say you
know I've got soul but I'm not a soldier
I'm not making a claim about the
interior animating principle of my being
I'm not making a claim about a
spiritually subsistent part of my myself
so you'll find times where nefes just
means you know a living person and we
use it that way with soul in English now
like there was not a soul in the room we
don't mean soul in a philosophical or
theological sense there we mean it in
this broader colloquial sense of a
person like we could also say there was
nobody there and we're also not just
referring to their body you notice you
can do that with soul or body and you
really mean like uh uh what is it called
synty like when you talk about a car is
a set of wheels but even though like
literally a car isn't just Wheels
correct correct talking about part of it
um okay uh so I I want to go into um and
again I want to be in the form of
questions here so I can have you answer
um implicitly here and explicitly but
so the soul doesn't have an end and to
you again that is stating that the soul
does not
die meaning for all eternity like the
soul just it depends what we mean by die
like the soul is not naturally
annihilated okay but the soul can can
enter into Eternal death like we believe
in Everlasting punishment so like in the
separation of sheep and goats when
Christ talks about some going to
everlasting life and some going to
Everlasting death the same adjective is
used to describe the the duration of
both life and death so
okay so I'm glad we're bringing that up
because I you know I want this to be
more conversational I know it's like
question I don't want to be so
interrogative but I don't I don't mind
it at all I you're not you're not
offending me at all okay yeah Matthew
2546 for the audience so we can clearly
understand um okay so in your in your
estimate in your understanding the
Matthew 25 the sheep and the goats
you're saying that the Everlasting uh
punishment is is the you're saying it's
punishing for all eternity it's eternal
from God right Eternal separation from
God but in your definition that means
that they are they are being punished
for all eternity like the punishing
continues on and on and on that that's
what Eternal punishment literally
means that's what if you have a life
sentence your sentence is for life if
you've got a punishment for eternity if
it's an eternal
punishment um correct so the the so your
your understanding of it is that yeah
they're eternally separated from God
right yes but to me that is the
punishment but to you you're saying that
is the punishment but you're stating
that their soul is going to be
eternally being punished for that
eternity so in other words I'm saying
that Eternal punishment I'm trying to
understand so when you say Eternal
punishment you're stating that they're
going to be punished for all eternity
meaning like there's an action that's
happening for all eternity with that
person if you want to talk about it as
an active as an action I mean it they
will go away into Eternal
punishment like if someone is serving a
life
sentence the sentencing in one sense I
guess you could say is going on for all
eternity the act of being sentenced but
obviously the judicial aspect is over in
a moment in both
cases okay yeah um but I the way I'm
seeing it is that when when God puts
those in Eternal punishment I mean
they're they are going to be destroyed
there are so many um so I don't I don't
see that at all in Matthew 25 46 like it
doesn't say Eternal punishment and they
won't experience it anymore than it says
the righteous are going to go into an
eternal life but they won't experience
it you have to add add some language to
the the passage to make
it the punishment of death right verse
41 and in verse
46 um sorry if you can scroll up to 41
miles right 41 uh speaks about the
Eternal fire that's prepared for the
devil and his angels okay then you go to
46 he's describing those who are going
to be cast into Eternal fire and then 46
these will go away into Eternal
punishment so the Eternal punishment is
now is equivalent to the Eternal fire
them being put in Eternal fire is the
same as them going into Eternal
punishment right but the righteous in
into eternal life so it's do you uh so
so how do you how let me see how do I
question this so I don't make I don't
want to make statements in the question
but how do you see
um the quality of eternal
your stating is describing the punish
the punishment as opposed to the uh yeah
the duration of the punishment obviously
is eternal meaning so the way I'm
looking at it is that the results of the
punishment is eternal but they're not
going to be punished for
eternity meaning the
punishment so okay so when we look at
other places that describe this right
like how do you harmonize your view with
like how Jude describes Sodom and
Gomorrah or how Peter describes Sodom
and Gomorrah when it's when they're
comparing that to how the wicked are
going to be at the end of the age right
so Jude 7 for example and second Peter
26 so how do you so in other words how
do you not see a total ending of the
wicked or of the unsaved from that point
um because I think the people in s
Gomorrah are enduring the punishment of
Eternal
fire but they're actually brought to
ashes I mean because you know you see
yeah sure but like if if you're thinking
of it bot then it's just not true like
there is not an eternal fire still going
on in Sodom and Gomorrah but if as Jude
is pointing out they're showing a
visible example of the reality of
Eternal fire then it's completely true
like Jude 17 points to the fact that the
people who rebelled against God and
Sodom and Gomorrah did not just suffer
physical death they suffer the
punishment of Eternal fire literally
it's it's right there in the text like
they don't just die they die and go to
hell the fire uh in Genesis actually
speaks of uh coming down from God right
sulfur and um fire Brimstone in the King
James right um
and that fire is uh you know
in terms of uh in terms of the act in
terms of the actual quality of that fire
that fire was eternal fire because it
came from the Eternal God no I wouldn't
describe it as Eternal fire no something
coming from God doesn't make it Eternal
fire it's not described that way in the
Old
Testament well it it does because it
doesn't it doesn't say that the fire so
the Eternal fire you're saying doesn't
doesn't go out does keeps burning
eternal
but it went out Everlasting right like
the the word here can mean Everlasting
which is is more again we translated
Eternal because that's the way we
normally use that word but it has a
beginning and no end like it isn't like
fire and brimstone has has eternally
coexisted with
God right it just comes from an eternal
being so this is what so do like the
planets that doesn't make the planets
Eternal okay that's what I'm saying so
Jude is saying that the fire that went
down on Sodom and Gomorrah was eternal
fire and they were and they suffered
that punishment and they were burnt up
I'm saying I think you're misreading the
passage that yes they did burn up and I
think this is referencing the fact that
they also experienced an eternal fire so
in terms of the way that the New
Testament authors read the Old Testament
they will view Vis like visible physical
events as signs of spiritual realities
that cannot be seen so for instance in 1
Corinthians chapter 10 when you have the
pillar of fire and the pillar of cloud
going before the Israelites and you have
The Parting of the Red Sea in 1
Corinthians 10 St Paul reads all of that
as an a prefigurement of baptism of
water in the spirit and and he describes
it in that way and then the eating of
the Mana and the drinking of the water
from the the rock is Supernatural food
and drink so it's he's he's doing these
things as prefigurement of things in the
Christian Life that aren't as visible to
the eyes so likewise the destruction of
Sodom and Gomorrah is a visible sign of
an invisible reality in this case the
invisible reality is what Jude 17
describes as Eternal fire he's not
claiming that the fire in Sodom or
Gomorrah was eternal physically it it
clearly was not it's not going on still
it has a beginning it has an end it
doesn't meet any definition of Eternal
that the fire is instead the one you
aren't seeing which is
hellfire okay
um so maybe if I may just add one more
thing
to I mean I mean was a couple of points
G to make one was the Greek on the on
the word Eternal does mean without
beginning without end but I mean I guess
you it can't it doesn't have to I agree
with you that it doesn't have to mean
that but it is the word used for each
even though the word can have other
meanings like with soul one of the
problems we have is a lot of important
biblical Concepts have words that don't
just have one and only one meaning so
like the word for worship there's not
one New Testament word for worship there
are several and none of the words only
mean worship so you can't just do
theology by concordance it doesn't work
you have to look at what did this author
mean by this one minute left Contex so
in this case um literally the verse let
me skip to it let me skip to one other
question because we only have one minute
and then you um question is is so is
there a hell burning right now yes okay
um Matthew he speaks of it in the past
and the separation of sheep and goats
like it has been prepared for the devil
and his
angels okay but when you contrast that
with Revelation 20 you actually see when
that actually happens when the devil and
his I know Adventists have very
idiosyncratic views on which parts they
do and take do do and don't take
literally and like the timeline with
Revelation but I don't think that's a
solid foundation to kind of build the
theology from I think again we're going
to get into the cross examination on on
your end um but I think what it is is
that there's there's there's a lot of
clarity way more clarity in scripture on
the uh result or the end of the of the
unsaved
time okay all right um all right I'm
gonna start actually with something that
I want to just make sure that everyone
involved kind of understands the
Adventist view of the relationship of
soul and body are you a fan of the kind
of box and Nails uh analogy or wooden
Nails analogy you know what I'm talking
about I do know I I do understand what
you're talking about but um I I go ahead
and and proceed well no I don't I don't
want to try to give it I was going to
give you a chance if you wanted to
explain it because I think that might
help uh
clarify kind of where you're coming from
theologically with the with what the
soul even
is yeah I I go back to Genesis
2:7 uh
yep so um I I come back to that that uh
we are a soul that we are living
creature you know living creature the
word soul and creature is the same uh is
the same Hebrew word um neesh so that's
that's where I stand is that we came
from the dust of the ground that's where
we return naturally uh and then what
gave us the life which came from God
that goes back to God but that in itself
is not an that is not that in itself is
not the soul uh Soul what you call that
Just Breath of Life the breath yeah the
breath or spirit that is yeah what are
the spiritual properties or what what
are the physical properties or whatever
you would call it of the breath like
does it have Consciousness do you have
like what is the breath you in any
sense I would say the breath in terms of
Genesis 2:7 um the breath is what is
what makes us a living being combined
saying when you die the breath goes to
God is there some sense in which you are
with God
or when when you die and your breath
goes to God is is that you with God in
any sense of the term you are in the
ground right so I'm asking I guess in
terms of a principle of identity who or
what is the breath I mean we can say it
comes from God is the breath God is the
breath you is the breath what it is life
it's life that God gives to the
dust so you and I guess I don't know
what it means for something to just be
it's the same thing it's the same it's
the same thing that gives the animals
life it is you know it is you know the
the the breath that the animals have
it's the same breath that we have right
so
once once at death that simply goes back
to God because that's where it came from
and we which we didn't come from there
we came from the ground we go back to
the ground I'm sure you
this is just it sounds like you're
actually maybe clarifying my question
this is not you this is just some other
thing it'd be like if movement left your
body and movement concept that leaves
you so you you so so here's the deal um
the way I view it is that your as a
Believer okay we're not gonna talk about
the unbeliever this point but as a
Believer right your life is is uh hid
with God in Christ right so Christ has
your life right so at death at natural
death at physical death that Earthly
death you are you are you still exist
you're just a corpse right you're just a
corpse your body's in the grave it
decomposes or whatever it is um and that
will be resurrected at the time at
Christ's coming you will no longer uh
have you know so and so yeah so that's
that's how I would view it so the life
the breath that God gave us is literally
life okay and struck by something
because you just said uh you are your
soul but then that when you die you are
in the grave but you don't have your
soul right like the breath is gone so
there's no soul right if I'm
understanding you correctly so soul is
your soul is not in the grave soul is
equivalent to me I a soul you're a soul
right okay so you know uh you know when
you when you pass away when I pass away
um we are in the grave that us we're in
the grave we are resting until the
resurrection so your soul is in the
grave you are in the grave I guess is it
true to say your Soul's in the grave or
not because if the question is like what
happens to your soul when you die I feel
like that's a really important question
to answer I would just say your soul
ceases to live okay so your soul doesn't
go to the Grave your soul just it
becomes annihilated is that fair to say
I your your your soul ceases to live
you're there's there's no you're you're
you are so in other words you right now
this Joe Hesh that I'm speaking to Matt
Maria that you're speaking to we are
souls right as soon as as soon as the
breath leaves and we are what we call
what we would call dead um it's not that
we don't have a soul it's just that our
soul ceases to live what is the
difference between not having a soul and
your soul ceasing to
live because we were given a soul at
Birth or we were given at Soul at were
in Adam at the Breath of Life um so I
would say yeah let me just reward this
just to make sure I would yeah I would
say that what was the difference between
you having a soul and you're not having
a soul and being dead is that what
you're saying no I'm saying so like it
sounds like you're saying the union is
the soul and that Union is broken in
death the union between breath and body
I would say I I I would say I would put
it this way you your soul your body all
that is resting in the grave oh so your
soul is resting in the
grave I would say your soul ceases to be
conscious you Seas to be conscious when
I say you see I'm not seeing a
separation between myself and and and my
soul I know you do but I don't see a
difference between that I'm just trying
to understand what it is you because it
sounds like you said nefesh living being
means the same thing as soul in your
theology but that a dead
being is dead and still has a living
Soul it's it's not by my theology it's
by what the Bible has says right so
living creature I'm not gonna say right
to that but I'm trying to I'm genuinely
trying to understand because I don't it
sounds like you're saying your soul
doesn't continue to be in existence but
it's not annihilated and it's it is and
isn't in the body still when you
die can you can you clarify that a
little more for me I would say your soul
is resting in the
grave okay is your soul still attached
to your or is is your body the same
thing as your soul at that
point um I would say again that the soul
is resting so I the way I would just
simply put it I mean maybe I never
thought of it in the in the contrast
you're putting it but because I think
again um you have this uh you again your
idea is that the soul and the body are
to don't worry about what I I believe
I'm trying to understand what you
believe your question is coming from
that premise and I think it's a false
premise okay so I don't know why the
question is your soul in your body is is
a false premise I just like to keep it
simple and keep it sticking with what
the Bible says and it says sleep whether
it means the soul is sleeping the body
is sleeping with the soul the point is
is that at death you are asleep and
there no consciousness in death but do
you see why like it sounds like if
you're saying well it doesn't really
matter if it's the body asleep or the
soul asleep but if the body asleep in
the grave like what Christians believe
and the soul is with God I mean non-
Adventists believe like that seems like
the exactly the debate we're having so
to just say like you haven't thought
about it I don't know it's a weird this
is literally the thing we're trying to
sort out isn't it like what happens to
your soul when you die
I I I'm just saying the Bible says it
sleeps okay but it is in the grave or
it's in the bosom of Abraham or it's in
Hades or the Bible doesn't explicitly
say the soul sleeps the Bible just says
that you know you are asleep it's like
it's almost like as if there's no that's
I I appreciate that distinction because
you're right the Bible never says the
soul sleeps correct right but because
then the question is clearly the body we
can describe the body at rest right is
that a fair at least a common ground
like someone you lay their body in the
grave and the early Christians who
believed in the soul still named these
places cemeteries like places of rest
and they put like rest in peace over it
and all that like we can talk about the
body clearly being at rest is that a
fair place of Common Ground sure yeah
okay and then the question just becomes
is there another component to your being
besides what's in the grave is that is
that fair I think um I mean to not again
to I just quickly stay with what the
scripture says but um um if you wanted
to you know but it doesn't I mean but I
think we already agreed you already said
the scripture doesn't say the soul
sleeps so God God has God has in
reserve the life that will be so in
Christ right so as a Believer all
believers have their Eternal Destiny
secured in
Christ okay so when it comes to the
Eternal Destiny at the resurrection this
is what Paul says this is what scripture
says that is when we will finally be ra
raised and going into eternity right
with 100% agree that like the full esy
the body either side is the union of
body and soul you are brought back to
life right I I don't so when I see soul
in the body in the Bible Soul refers
simply in more ways than not it's just
you as the person right so the person so
how do you apply that to something like
Matthew 10:28 like when Jesus says do
not fear Those Who Kill the body cannot
kill the soul rather fear Him who can
destroy both soul and Body in Hell
correct what does that mean in your view
it it's talking about the Eternal
Destiny of the human being right God has
control of the entire Eternal Destiny
right man can only man can only destroy
you physically but it can't destroy your
Eternal
Destiny I I don't understand what not
physical what is this other part the
word the word Soul there is life and by
the way the word Soul there can be
destroyed as well which I know you don't
okay wait wait yeah I I agree the soul
can be destroyed in the sense of Eternal
death but kill the body would that's not
what that's talking about that's talking
let's let's look specifically at Matthew
10:28 when Jesus says do not fear those
who could kill the body but cannot kill
the soul in your theology how can
someone kill the
body separating the Breath of Life from
the corpse the word Soul there means
life
what does that mean what does that mean
so if you go to Luke 12 to go to the
parallel text it'll tell you what that
means uh Luke 12 verse uh verse4 I tell
you my friends do not fear Those Who
Kill the body and after that have
nothing more that they can do okay what
more can So What by implication more can
be done after your body is killed
Eternal damnation I mean it's literally
in the next verse exactly but I warn you
whom to fear fear Him who after he has
killed has authority to cast into hell
yes I tell you to so here it's it's it's
obviously talking about the Eternal
Destiny
right has total control of Eternal
Destiny it's obviously God that's what
he's saying and and I understand I'm not
asking who who is the one we should be
fearing I'm asking what is the
distinction between body and soul in
Matthew 10 and how is it possible on an
Adventist theology to kill the body
without also killing the body body body
is the body is the Earthly life and soul
in this case in the context of the
Eternal destiny which is what compared
to what Luke 12 is is bring out okay so
it's inter so it sounds like sometimes
you think soul is something other than
the Breath of Life Soul means life in
this context that's exactly what the
Greek word is implying here same way
where says spiritual eternal life or or
no in this context yeah it depends on
the context and the text okay I'm I'm
just trying to make sure that we
understand so God has control has the
authority which is what Luke says God
has the authority of where the spiritual
Destiny can go therefore don't fear when
you're preaching in my name is what the
context of Matthew 10 is about Matthew
10 is not about a it's not he's not
Matthew 10:28 is not explaining there's
two different parts of the human uh of
why does he distinguish Body and Soul if
he doesn't think there's a distinction
between Body and
Soul he's not distinguishing between
body and soul I just mentioned I mean he
literally in the text in Matthew 10:28
uses the term Som and then is it Psy I
can't remember if it's when you
understand the soul as life that's what
that means your life can be destroyed
your soul can die you can die like and
and then those who are uh cast into hell
unfortunately are going to be completely
annihilated and that is compl so they're
gonna die not just bodily but Also
spiritually is that a fair thing to say
ories that's why called the second death
Joe okay no I'm I'm trying to understand
because even in second death we would
say there's a clear distin between
bodily and spiritual death no the second
death is a complete total Destruction
which is coherent with every other place
that it speaks of unquenchable Fire um
or you know fire and brimstone it is
talking about complete utter destruction
that is the imagery of Sodom and
Gomorrah which I was getting at earlier
that is the imagery of what the wicked
shows in all of scriptures there's many
scriptures where it has these imageries
whether you call them metaphors or not
the metaphors are meant to have a
certain picture in your head and is
complete destruction here in Matthew
let's look at Luke 16 then because I
don't see that complete destruction in
Luke 16 well Luke 16 is not even talking
about hell okay talking about Hades
Sayes Hades and hell are different
spiritually Hades and hell are different
yes okay so he's in torment in Hades
what is that in comparison say
1623 the rich man is in Hades in torment
is that bodily torment or spiritual
torment okay so obviously this is a
parable right um do you believe why does
that matter actually I'm not I'm not
100% sure it is obvious that it's a
parable he names Lazarus who is a real
life human being who's also mentioned in
John 11
maybe there's a real Lazarus and a fake
Lazarus I I don't know what obvious
about this being a
parable um because he names names does
it mean it's not a parable what's
another Parable he names names I believe
Ezekiel
33 I believe Jesus gave a parable in
Ezekiel 33 you don't believe Jesus was a
speaker in the Old Testament um I think
Ezekiel is speaking through prophetic
wisdom for the Holy Spirit but uh I'm
talking about Jesus's Parables I mean I
don't think but either way I mean okay
but it's feels like a digression word of
the Lord came to me and it's son of it's
voting verbatim from from the Lord so
you know in Jesus's parables in the New
Testament when Jesus is actually
speaking not not speaking of like
scriptural inspiration are there any
places where he names someone by name in
a
parable is there what are there any
places in Jesus's Parables which Jesus
is clearly speaking in the New Testament
where he gives a parable but still names
one person by
name no but it doesn't mean that
therefore that warrants this to be a
real story uh well whether it's whether
it's real or Parable I'm not what is the
significance of it being a parable in
your
view um he's teaching a lesson to the
Pharisees about covetousness and about
uh treating people fairly okay why why
does it matter that it's a parable and
not literal
okay so if it's literal um I mean do you
imagine that the Great Gulf between the
righteous and the Wicked the righteous
can still actually reach the
wicked
yeah and okay I mean sorry not not
between the righteous and the wicked
between the righteous and those on Earth
Abraham says there's an abyss that
cannot pass and you think the righteous
and those on Earth and how big is
Abraham's
chest it's spiritual it's literal but
it's still spiritual that doesn't make
it a parable like it's not that Abraham
is bodily there so let me ask a question
then I know you're asking me the
question so let's just I yeah so I I
gave my uh answer of why this is a
parable why you save that I have a
couple other questions I want to talk
about the witch of indor in the witch of
indor is that a parable or or do you
think that actually happen finish Luke
16 um I would I want to know more about
it but I don't feel like I'm getting a
lot of of clear answers of L 16 is
following a series of Parables Luke 15
Luke even if it's a parable why would
Jesus give a theologically heretical
parable so I think Jesus speaks in the
common thought of the day so would he
give a parable about like reincarnation
or something if people thought
reincarnation was real I mean I mean I
don't know he never we don't have that
in scripture but we do have in scripture
him using Idols to speak to people like
Nebuchadnezzar I don't think that was an
idol I think it's a statue but I mean
that gets into again a whole
other that's exactly what I mean what
what was that sure okay even if you want
to call it an idol he's not presenting
that as good like four Kingdoms in
Daniel 2 aren't a positive right they're
the oppressors of
Israel what what I'm saying is that
there's a there's there's clear picture
where Jesus is speaking in the common
thought of the of the people he was
speaking to but where does he endorse
something radical for the S of and there
there are and there and there are early
right that that describe that this story
was a common story being told as well
especially amongst the Pharisees because
in there in their in and there according
to the history they had the rich man
going to heaven and the poor man not I
mean I don't know the the history of it
but are read saying Jesus just took like
one of the existing stories and didn't I
mean I guess here here's the framework
I'm coming from Jesus could tell us the
nature of the
afterlife say that one more time who can
what Who besides Jesus could tell us the
nature of the afterlife I mean obviously
only Jesus right and so if Jesus hears
people have this totally heretical
understanding of the afterlife why in
the world would he give a parable that
reinforces it and doesn't correct it so
why seems like all all you've gained is
accumulating wealth is bad a message
he's made over and over again and then
in the course of that and they obviously
didn't get he actually pointed them to
scripture and said that even if someone
rose from the dead they won't even
listen but but let but Jesus also gave
Parables about uh you know uh gouging
your a did he literally uh endorse that
no those are those are exaggerations but
there also weren't people going around
there are examples where Jesus can teach
using exaggerations oh absolutely I
totally agree that he can teach you to
exaggerations and this is one minute
left so this is an exaggeration because
it sounds like you're saying this is
actually like a false thing Jesus is
teaching um I think going into Abraham's
bosom is a big exaggeration I think
that's a representation of what the
common mindset was that hey when you
died you know remember the Pharisees
believed in transmigration of the Soul
they almost believe it like basically
reincar some did right but but he
doesn't teach transmigration of the soul
in Luke that what I'm saying is that
Jesus is taking a common thing he wasn't
going to go against the grain of
thinking at that time at at at this time
in Luke 16 he wasn't going to go against
the grain of thinking of the Pharisees
okay I think I've got time for one last
question um do you endorse the SDA
website's belief that this is coming
from the third Century from platonic
philosophy show me where that reference
is on the websit it's the article what
is your soul according to the Bible
where where's this at can you yeah sure
it's adventist.org death and
Resurrection you already gave that
before slash what is your soul according
to the Bible with dashes between all
those I don't time I'll put a link in
the chat we're gonna have to hold off on
that question and The Witch of Endor
until your next section this is exactly
why we're going to do another round of
this now thank you gentlemen this has
been a very exciting discussion we're
going to reverse now and it's back to
Matt for questioning your 20 minutes
second 20 minute section final one will
begin when you begin talking sir okay um
yeah let's go to the witch of Endor
actually um and let's go to 1 Samuel 28
if you don't mind yeah none of all
um so question uh
Joe do you believe that um you do
understand that God spoke through
prophets obviously right and God spoke
and God spoke his will to Israel through
uh Samuel I do okay um
and Samuel obviously in this chapter is
passed away he's dead um and do you also
know and understand that you know God
forbade uh any of his people speaking to
you know uh you know familiar spirit
yep you understand that was a command
completely uh God forbade that and do
you think Saul knew
that okay um do you also believe at this
time in Saul's life that he was uh that
God was not speaking to him anymore I
believe it says that
explicitly okay so verse
six okay so why would why would God uh
why would god um bring
out why would God so first off why would
God work with a familiar Spirit of whom
he forbids to do that uh and bring
Samuel the real Samuel from the dead
well I mean it we're told that he did
the question of why does God do what
he's going to do is a second question no
it says it says Samuel said in verse 16
and it also says in in verse 14 Saul
knew it was Samuel I mean it it very
explicitly over and over affirms that
it's not a demon pretending to be Samuel
it really is Samuel and moreover Samuel
uh accurately prophesies the imminent
death of Saul which comes true the next
day um actually Saul perceived it was it
doesn't say it actually was Samuel it
says in verse 14 Saul knew it was
Samuel and then verse 15 said then
Samuel said to Saul verse 16 and Samuel
said to Saul verse 20 says he was filled
with fear because of the words of Samuel
like the idea that this isn't really
Samuel is is completely contrary to the
text repeated uh affirmations that it
isn't fact if you so so you believe that
the um souls go to heaven when they die
like did old test here before the the
so-called heroine of hell so first Peter
3 explicitly describes this major
transition point so if is it okay I
don't know if I can do this on the
answering end but can we pull up first
Peter
3 sure thing well before you go to First
just just repeat what you said again so
you said so Samuel was where when he was
dead uh he's in the grave it's it's a a
little more ambiguous in the Old
Testament because there hasn't been
What's called the heroine of hell so you
have the righteous dead and what's
sometimes called the bosom of Abraham
like in Luke 16 uh and the term shaol is
used as a catchall both for the place of
the abod of the righteous dead and the
wicked dead later in Greek Hades will
come to be used to refer specifically to
the place of the wicked dead and not the
righteous dead but in the earlier
hebraic usage it it just is using this
kind of catchall so you're say that in
the New Testament Hades or the grave is
not the place for the righteous I'm
saying Hades
specifically Hades and gehenna are used
for the place of
Torment G was
not gehenna yeah the fires of gehenna
are explicitly mentioned as like as a
description of hell
right Kenna was a literal place outside
of Jerusalem but it's used in a
non-literal way to describe the the
fires of
damnation uh this is oh is that uh James
F let me I'll find it um in the meantime
first Peter 3 oh sorry James James 3 not
jameses and it's used 11 times in the
gospels GNA that's what you're referring
to Pardon gehenna you're you're
referring to gehenna yeah it is when
James describes it as being the the son
excuse me the tongue being an
unrighteous member set on fire by the
fires of Hell the word there is
literally
GNA okay but everywhere else it's spoken
of 11 times in the gospel and Jesus is
speaking to Jews yeah it's like
Armageddon like megiddo is a real place
and it also has a metaphorical use like
if I said something is like the mecca of
such and such you would understand the
difference between me speaking
geographically and metaphorically I
think
but I wanted if I may answer your your
earlier question about 1 Peter 3 uh
looking specifically at beginning in
verse 18 says that Christ died for sins
once for all the righteous for the
unrighteous that he might bring us to
God being put to death in the flesh but
made alive in the spirit and numi is is
the Greek word there so you see that
flesh Spirit distinction in which he
went and preached to the spirits in
prison who formerly did not obey so
these are not just like demons or
something these are human Souls uh
Numa spirits who formerly did not obey
when God's patience waited in the days
of Noah during the building of the Ark
in which a few that is eight person
that's when they were preached to that's
when they were preached that's when they
were preached to in the days of Noah
when the ark Was
preparing through Noah no it says in
which he went and preached to the
spirits in prison Yeah Yeah by the
spirit he preached through Noah that's
consistent what Peter said if you go to
First Peter it talks about the prophets
had the spirit of Christ not saying the
prophets didn't have the spirit of
Christ although Noah is never described
as a prophet I'm saying verse 19 does
not say uh he preached in the days of
Noah it says he went and preached to the
spirits in prison yeah and formerly did
not obey
rightey even if you say Noah to them
before and they formerly did not obey
no sorry to interrupt you but this is
what we can call you know spiritual
death here is that those that are and
Disobedience are in spiritual death
spiritual death is not the death that
God had you know mentioned is there a
question okay I'm just saying we're
we're um yeah so um yeah back to the
question of Samuel since you you know we
can go into first Peter 3 uh I'm giving
that just as an explanation that there's
a clear turning point which is the early
Christians called the heroine of hell
and you can see this for instance
there's a second century homy that talks
about Christ so you're Peter 3 the
question would be when were these
Spirits in prison being preached to yeah
Holy Saturday it I mean it's it's pretty
clear he was put to death in the flesh
made alive in the spirit in which notice
in which in the spirit he went so
already Christ not physically but
spiritually look at the transition from
18 to 19 he's dead in the flesh but
alive in the spirit and he went now did
he go bodily of course not he's in the
Tomb bodily he went spiritually and
preach to Spirits in prison verse
19 I don't I don't agree with your um
observation there I I it it I mean how
do you deal with Genesis 6 where it's
clearly showing his Spirit not striving
with the anti delians um Noah preaching
I think it's fine to say Noah also
preached but that's not first Peter 3
has nothing to do with Noah
preaching it doesn't say a word about
Noah preaching it says that they not
obey when God's patience waited in the
days of it's it's talking about is it
not talking about how Jesus Was Made
Alive in by the
spirit in in what verse which which part
are you talking about Verse 18 is it not
talking about Jes how so in other words
in which because it's describing how he
was it was describing the work of the
holy spirit is it not from Verse 18 it
doesn't say that
no it talks about Christ physically
being dead and spiritually being alive
and how was he made
alive because he's God he doesn't we
don't believe he leaves his divinity
aside like he commends his Spirit into
the father's hand as he as he's dying so
there I mean there's a probably a
complicated trinitarian question to that
but the last words Christ utters on the
cross are father into your hands I
commit my spirit and spirit there
doesn't seem to be you know he's losing
personal Identity or his soul is is
being destroyed or anything like that
his soul is being committed into the
hands of the father and he has this
mission of redemption and one aspect of
the mission of redemption is preaching
to the souls who died how did he
Proclaim how did he preach to the
spirits in what in in in what form did
he do that in the spirit
right right are you asking how do
spirits communicate no no that's not
what I'm asking I'm asking in the text
how did he preach to the spirits in
prison by how by what means uh he went
and preached to them how in the SP
Numa yeah by the spirit right I know
it's a word between in the spirit and by
the spirit I Believe by the spirit is
the proper interpretation I know we're
using okay if you want to say who's Made
Alive by this but that changes the the
meaning to a place where I think becomes
incomprehensible if you say he was put
to death in the flesh but made
physically alive that just because of
the because how do you then because it
does that perfectly is harmony with what
you read in First Peter in the beginning
of his
book I I don't go to First Peter 1 verse
10 and
11 how do you harmonize you know so how
do you not see the harmony between 1
Peter 318 and 19 and 20 to 1 Peter 1:
10-1 if you can put that up miles yeah I
think I think there's a perfect harmony
between those the prophets who
prophesied of the grace that was to be
yours searched and inquired about this
salvation they inquired what person or
time was indicated by the spirit of
Christ within them when predicting the
sufferings of Christ and the subsequent
Glory so here the prophetic Ministry had
been pointing towards Christ's death and
glorious Resurrection first Peter but
how what we're we're seeing is here in
verse 10 concerning the Salvation the
prophets who prophesied how did they
prophesy by the spirit the spirit what
was in them the spirit of Christ was in
them that's what if if first Peter 3 had
said Noah prophesied to people of old
and they didn't listen that would be
true that happens not to be at all what
the text disobedient mean what were they
disobedient to uh the patience of God
and his Commandments to
them pardon so you're saying they were
dis okay so how are they disobedient and
the and in because God had already given
his command to people there's no
reference anywhere in Genesis 6 to Noah
going on a mission of like prophecy like
where does he where does Noah preach
anywhere in Genesis 6 it just it doesn't
exist there like you're you're adding
all that to the biblical text to make
this interpretation work but it's just
not
there like listen specifically in in
Genesis 6 verse3 God's message to Noah
is I have determined to make an End of
All Flesh for the Earth is filled with
violence through them notice they're
they're disobeying they're in violence
even though Noah hasn't said word one to
them in the text behold I will destroy
them with uh second Peter was looking
for the text second Peter chapter 2 and
verse
5 if he did not spare the ancient world
but preserved Noah a Herald of
righteousness with seven other persons
when he
brought a preacher of righteousness so
okay there there's the connection so
you're saying there's like an unspoken
prophetic Ministry that Noah has that
Genesis doesn't
record I I believe that the text in
second Peter clears it up that Noah did
preach that requir be a literal verbal
Proclamation that's and that's what
first Peter 3 is is is uh commenting on
is the fact that in this that through
Noah the spirit of Christ through Noah
preached to those in the time of the
flood while the ark Was preparing while
look at first Peter three and and you'll
see that it doesn't have Noah doing the
active preaching there even if you want
to say that implicit within verse 20 is
that Noah had preached and they that was
how they rejected that when they
formerly didn't obey they didn't obey
something Noah preached that that
Genesis doesn't tell us about even if
you want to imagine that that still
doesn't make the active one going and
preaching in verse 19 Noah it's Jesus
you can just look at the way the the
sentence reads it it mean it is clearly
and explicitly Christ like Jesus
preached through all the prophets which
is what First Peter 1 says so you think
when it says Christ preached this means
this was the
unwritten prophetic Ministry of
Noah yes okay I mean it it does your
case kind of turn on that I know we're
kind of switching I think because of the
translation of the word in versus the
word uh versus what I think is more
proper the word by in verse 18 okay so I
just want to point out in this you have
to take a non-standard reading of what
in the spirit means and a non-standard
reading of what verse 20 means about
God's patience for the wicked in the
days of Noah and a non-standard reading
of who's doing the preaching to the
spirits in prison and we still haven't
gotten to where there are spirits in
prison so I mean the the number of
exegetical things we would have to grant
for your interpretation to uh even be
plausible I can understand if you said
you know the majority reading is X I
think y on one thing but we're talking
about four things in three verses where
you have to say oh the way it is in
every Bible is actually wrong it means a
totally different thing and I just think
that is a a a very implausible way of
doing theology no I think it's just
consistent with the with the teaching of
scripture on the but what teach if
you're teaching of scripture is that
everyone is misreading all of these
critical verses and and even
interpreting them and mistranslating
them the fact that Jesus was in the
grave he didn't go anywhere until until
the uh first until Sunday until
Resurrection morning okay so I want to
make sure that that part is clear
because I think this is why this really
matters that you cannot have Jesus going
or doing anything in verse 19 right
because he is put to Death In the Flesh
so your your timing is off on that the
timing that Jesus did this was during
the time of the flood when the arcs were
pring that's literally what it
says uh it says he went and preached in
the timing of the flood or it says they
former did not obey notice that word
formerly if verse 19 is about the days
of
Noah then you wouldn't say you wouldn't
refer to the next event their
disobedience is happening formerly
because it would happen
contemporaneously like if I've got a
play said in the 1870s and there's an
event in the 1870s I wouldn't say
formerly in 1870 such and such because
we would already be in 1870 so verse 19
is already back in Genesis 6 you
wouldn't be using the word formerly to
describe the Disobedience of the people
in the days of Noah because they would
already be in the days of Noah in verse
19 if that was a plausible
reading yeah I I don't think the
explanation you gave really distorts The
View that is being portrayed here in the
text so you think this is really just a
text about how people disobeyed
Noah so in which he went by the spirit
right and proclaimed or preached to the
spirits in prison because they
form
Jesus Jesus jesuses Jesus Through Noah
Jesus Through the prophets by the spirit
he preached through the prophets by the
spirit he preached through Noah at the
time I want I want to make sure that we
understand we're looking at 18 to 20 as
a paropy and it says Christ also died
for sins once for all the righteous for
the unrighteous but that we're supp to
expect halfway through it has a
digression about Noah preached to people
back in
Genesis at the time that at the time
when this happened they didn't obey what
time was this getting specific when
God's patience waited in the days of
Noah while the art I noticed you skipped
the
formerly that I just said the word forly
just literally is pointing back to that
time right at that time right uh you
know other versions for time don't mean
the same thing they they don't like
those kind of mean opposite
things like I said you and I debated
formerly versus you and I are debating
at this time word for just means in the
time past right we're sometime in the
past disobedient that's literally what
the rendering
is okay I mean so again so Jesus went by
the Spirit uh and he speaking again
about the spirit's the quality of the
spirit right he's speaking about the
spirit that made Jesus alive the same
spirit that Jesus through that Spirit
went and preached to those in prison who
in the time past formally right sometime
in the past formally did not disobey
what kind of past is he talking about
what kind of people is he talking about
what part is he bringing this up to when
God's patience waited in the days of
Noah while the ark was being prepared
which in a few that is eight persons
were brought safely through the water
and he's contrasting that with baptism
so so to to be clear in this uh
reinterpretation of First Peter when is
Noah's prophetic Ministry when when is
Noah's prophetic Ministry compared to
the building of the Ark so I say that
one time when is what when is Noah's
prophetic Ministry in relationship to
the building of the
Ark what do you mean when is his
prophetic Ministry did he preach to them
before he built the ark or did he preach
to them while he's building the ark or
or what I I mean you've got a timeline
that that imagin know as a preacher and
apparently went out preaching because uh
the word heral could like it says here
while the ark was
beinged okay so do we know what he
preached do we know any of that so let
me ask you a question right because I
think the time one minute okay where do
you else do you see a clear picture of
Jesus going anywhere in between his
death and Resurrection St Paul says that
to say he ascended we have to say he
first descended that's not a reference
to the Grave which based on the fact
that he's buried in a cave um was
literally not a physical descent this is
a a realm a a spiritual
descent yeah that that's not a clear
Ephesians I'm sorry not not Ephesians 4
hang on I'm sorry let
me yeah it's Ephesians 4:9 I think
in saying he ascended what does it mean
but that he also descended into the
lower parts of the earth he who
descended is he who also ascended far
above all the heavens that he might fill
all things and
time great work
gentlemen all right we will now reverse
Joe for your final 20 minutes of cross
examination to ask Matt questions you
can keep it sort of this open format you
guys have been doing I know it's
sometimes hard to restrict it to only
asking questions and not be somewhat
conversational the time will begin when
you start talking sir okay uh thanks and
let's maybe stick with the theme of Holy
Saturday for a minute while while we're
here so in your view what happens to
Jesus when he dies what I mean what
happens because I guess do you have the
view that he has a human soul or I maybe
maybe I'm not even using the right terms
he just has the Breath of God within him
what was your question because I what
what happens to Jesus when he dies on
the cross like where like obviously
bodily we can talk about him as being in
the grave is that it does he can we talk
about Jesus still existing um because if
you said the soul is the person and the
soul is the union of breath and body if
Jesus's breath isn't in his body is
Jesus
non-existent no he was not living at
that time he was dead like the Bible
says he died I want to know what you
think it means when when it says
dead because we both agree that Jesus is
dead but I think it means every I think
it means just like it says in scripture
everywhere else he was resting in the
grave okay so bodily he's in the grave
is that it he doesn't have any other
presence anywhere
else his presence was in the grave that
was true that's where he was maybe
you're answering my question I can't
tell if you are I'm asking if he had any
presence outside of the Grave so telling
me that he's also in the grave doesn't
tell me if he also I'm not gonna get
into like the intricacy between the
Divinity and Humanity we do know that
that we do know that he humbled himself
and became uh a human and as a human he
died um other than that he rested in the
grave that's all we're
told I don't want to speak for you it
sounds like you're sort of nodding to
the fact that you don't think he's
Divine at this point is that right no
that's not he was always even while he
was a human he he he he clothed is he
holding the cosmos in in being while all
of this is happening well don't forget
too there's also the father and the
spirit that are also yeah but I'm asking
specifically is the second person of the
the Trinity or God the son or whatever
you want to call him is he sustaining
the universe and being again all we're
told in terms of his Humanity he was in
the grave and he rested in the
grave okay so came out on then he came
back out on Sunday I'm not going to get
into the you know intricacies of his
divinity because that's not the the
purpose of this topic is does death does
the bible teach death is asleep and we
see Jesus sleeping in the
grave yeah so if if we mean bodily sleep
like if we mean that the body lies in
the grave I think that's an
uncontroversial I think that's a point
AG I don't see this big distinction
between bodily it's as much as you bring
it up I don't see the scripture really
emphasizing that when it comes to okay
so you don't see anything about spirits
being in prison or anything like
that like I said that's the prison House
of sin and and and contextually in 1
Peter 3:18 verse 19 explains what that
means and that means being disobedient
like I was saying before like I was
saying before it's about being
spiritually dead they were spiritually
dead by being disobedient that's why in
Ephesians 2 it talks about that you know
we were dead in trespasses and sin let's
let's assume that that interpretation
for a about how does that make sense of
First Peter 3 so it's saying Christ died
for sins once for all he died in the
body on that Joe your timing is saying
that he did that after he died on the
cross what is the point of Peter's
sentence I mean whe whether you think
it's chronological or not about the work
of the Holy Spirit and how powerful that
Holy Spirit was and that it preached
through the anti delians through Noah
and we know Noah preached that's what
second Peter says okay your argument
said that there's progressive revelation
so now if you go to the next book second
Peter 2 it kind of It kind of sheds
light that Noah did preach and that's
how you can understand this passage very
clearly it uses the word Herald it's a
word not used anywhere else in the New
Testament and you think that means a
literal verbal preaching inspired by the
Holy Spirit not not the act of making
the ark According to second Peter 2 Noah
is a preacher of righteousness according
to Herald of righteousness is is what it
says I'm I'm going with the RSV because
on the Adventist website they said to
use a literal translation and gave this
one as an example of one to use you can
find one that says preacher but the word
used there is only it's a it's the only
time it's used in the New Testament it's
not the word for
preacher okay I okay wait what are you
talking about in second Peter 2 yeah
like there is a a word for preacher used
uh in other places for instance in 1
Timothy 2 when St Paul says he was
appointed a preacher an apostle uh in
second Timothy 1 when he says heral the
preer I mean it sounds like they're yeah
a Herald yeah so you're you're assuming
that means like a verbal Ministry not
the act of building the
ark I mean I think it include both okay
so in First Peter 3 why is he bringing
up that God wants preached by Noah in
the context of Jesus dying and you know
being alive in this Spirit or Alive by
the spirit I think he's transitioning
into baptism which he does later on and
he's working uh on the work of the
spirit okay can you help me see the kind
of thematic like so he's just changing
topics kind of mid
sentence uh no he's speaking of the
spirit preaching through Jesus during
the time when the ark was being prepared
and then he transitions into the water
and then he brings in baptism right
there in verse 21 so I definitely see
the connection between the Waters of the
flood and the baptismal Waters I'm I'm
with you on that and I I see how he says
you know baptism which corresponds this
now saves you you know I believe me as a
Catholic we like Hammer people with
first Peter
3:21 the question I've got is if this
doesn't have anything to do with Holy
Saturday or like what happens between
when Christ dies and rises again why is
this what Peter ising bringing up at
this moment is it just to find a way to
talk about
baptism like I mean it seems like you're
saying that he changes the topic he's
saying Christ died and he rose and also
Noah once preached to some people when
he built the ark and baptism now saves
you and I I don't know how
that it's like it seems almost like
you're saying Peter got
distracted no in context he's talking
about uh having a good conscience which
is what it mentions in verse 16
right it's better to suffer to do good
in verse 17 uh you know than to suffer
for doing evil um Christ suffered as
well righteous for the unrighteous he's
bringing out his sufferings that he
might bring us to God being put to death
in the flesh but then Was Made Alive in
the spirit and then he's going to this
parenthetical thing to go back into what
he was mentioning ah I see so it is it
is kind of a parenthe so you can't read
it as flowing logically you have to read
it as a parenthetical kind of a side
you're reading the whole chapter in
context yeah we have to make sure we're
keeping in context of what he just
mentioned before because he brings up
this he brings up the topic again let's
if if we may jump back to the witch of
Endor um what evidence do you have from
the text like again just looking at the
text itself that this wasn't Saul or
excuse me wasn't
Samuel um so the first off if it's a
witch number one um I don't believe that
witches are going I don't think God's
going to work with witches or speak
through witches or work through witches
um to you know bring up uh to bring up a
uh you know to bring up the dead that's
definitely not that's definitely against
that's the contradictory to his own
testimony um according to even Isaiah 8
you know in the context of necromancy
and Witchcraft you know to the law to
the testimony if they don't speak
according to this word there's no light
in them so there's no light in this
witch at all um God God won't work
through her at all
no no not at all when Samuel gives a
prophecy especially with Saul because
longer God's no longer communicating
with Saul um okay when when Samuel gives
a prophecy beginning in uh verse 15 when
he describes the
situation uh Saul describes the
situation of the Philistines and all
this and then Samuel rebukes him for
turning to him you're saying that's
actually the like what the witch or the
demon or something that's telling him
not to turn to Demons or
you know that the devil can transform
himself to an angel of Light that's
definitely what would be more consistent
with what's happening here okay so this
is actually the devil just to make sure
I'm understanding I don't want to put
words in your mouth perhaps I said the
word perhaps
right I'm wondering how you read the
passage because if it's Samuel I think
we can agree he's spiritually aware of
what's going on so You' have to say this
can't really be Samuel it has to be
something or someone else a demon the
devil a I don't know maybe a ghost or
something well also she also references
that she saw Gods coming out from uh
from the ground you know um again you
think so do you think this is the work
of the Lord I think he gives a prophecy
so let's Analyze That prophecy um Can
the devil give prophecies about the
future that that come true because this
is one of the marks of a true Prophet
compared to a false one right well all
we can deduce is that we knew that the
spirit of the Lord departed from SE and
I believe uh the evil spirit went into
him so I think this I think I think the
devil or the demons can accurately
predict that what was going to happen to
him for not you're saying the demons can
accurately predict the future so could a
false prophet then make predictions
about the
future um I'm not saying wait I'm not
saying a false prophet made predictions
about the future what I'm saying is that
so 1 Samuel 28 verse
19 yeah I think I think that I think
that's that's 100% I think that Satan
can deduce on or his demons can deduce
what would happen to soul for dis obing
the Lord knowing that he was a king of
high Authority um knowing the thing that
he knew he knew way better he had uh
great resp you think just a
probabilistic kind of guess or you think
it's an actual do you think it's a
prophecy or just a
guess no separation from God brings
death yes and so specifically in 1
Samuel 28 verse 19 when hang on just
just make sure I'm asking the question
in 1st Samuel 28 vers 19 somebody and
the text says it's Samuel but you say
it's not somebody says the Lord will
give Israel also with you into the hand
of the Philistines and tomorrow you and
your sons shall be with me so the death
of Samuel of Saul excuse me and his sons
is predicted to the day as is the defeat
of Israel's armies and I don't know who
has the spiritual power to do that but
from
God and I guess I'm asking you how is
that not the ual biblical test we're
supposed to use for separating a a true
from a false prophet if there are
predictions about the future the next
day so I mean it's not a hard prophecy
to to give and say that this is what's
going to happen I mean soul I think I
actually Mis heard what you said could
you say that again sa Saul was going to
fight the next day so it wasn't hard for
him to give that prophecy okay so it's
just a guess I think I I I I think um
without getting too much into this topic
of you know how much the Satan knows and
the demons know but I think they know
enough to be able to accurately uh you
know they they see they they can see the
uh the the Silver Lining here in other
words go back to Deuteronomy 18
20-22 what's that let's go to
Deuteronomy 18 20 to
22 so in Deuteronomy 18 there is this
question where if you say in your heart
how may we know the word which the Lord
has not spoken and we're told when a
prophet speaks in the name of the Lord
if the word does not come to pass or
come true that is a word which the Lord
has not spoken the prophet has spoken it
presumptuously you need not be afraid of
him so it doesn't mean a it doesn't mean
that it doesn't mean that just because
it came true it's not a false prophet if
you go to verse 20 um if the prophet who
presumes to speak a word in my name that
I have not commanded him to speak or who
speaks in the name of other gods the
same Prophet shall die doesn't mean that
the prophet can't say anything that's
true or that just because it said it was
true it's from God okay so you think
like even if you have accurate
prophecies about events in the future
that could still be the devil how does
the devil have that kind of knowledge
about the future in in this view I don't
know one day we'll find out but all we
know is that it's clearly seen here that
Saul departed from God he completely
left God we know that death is a we you
know it's not like it's not like it
wasn't uh known on what was happening
when you did these things I mean look
what happened in the wilderness when
they disobeyed the Lord I mean they were
instantly killed
uh some people were um Saul being in the
position that he was in 100% being in
the Rebellion that he was in and again
the spirit of God departed from from
Saul and an evil spirit took over him so
this can be something that's easily
shown as hey this is what happens when
you disobey God and you give yourself
out to him it's not that God You can
predict future or which which thing
happens I mean I I couldn't tell you oh
you're gonna die
tomorrow these are these are wicked
listen what does Ephesians 6 tell us
right we want to wrestle not with flesh
and blood principalities powers and
wicked Jonathan because it's not just
it's not just Saul who dies his sons
also die so is that just another lucky
guess no I think that's also reflective
of them departing from God as well so
you think you think Jonathan departed
from
God no I'm saying a result of Sauls
departing from God okay I think that's
what it is so if this is a demon or if
it is the devil
here here why does ver refer if you go
to job right I mean I guess you're
asking the questions but I'm trying to
answer you as well go ahead I didn't
hear what you were saying there I
apologize yeah I was saying in in in job
you see you clearly see a conversation
between God and Satan and you clearly
see that God allows Satan to do certain
things um I mean is so Satan knew that
he was going to kill job's kids he knew
he was going to destroy he knew what he
was going to do it's it's not really an
impressive prediction if I know tomorrow
I'm gonna have Mexican food for lunch
like it's an impressive prediction if I
know like what's going to happen to
somebody else tomorrow uh you know that
knowing what he's gonna do himself in
this situation in this situation in this
situation where Saul Saul is going to a
familiar Spirit right uh at that point
Satan is is who knows what conversation
if there was a conversation because it
seems like Satan was able to converse
with God at least uh you know at least
we see in job one I I could I could if
you say I see biblical support for Satan
conversing with God do we have biblical
support for God giving Satan privileged
knowledge about the future it's not
privileged knowledge about the future he
can just tell them hey take his
life okay yeah he could does it does it
say that in the text or does it say the
Lord will give Israel into the hand of
the Philistines say that in the text but
there there's clear it's clearly showing
that this Witch of which God has
commanded that is people not go and seek
after familiar spirits we clearly know
that Saul was not in the will of God
there and God was not working through
that Spirit to speak to Saul how does
God speak he speaks through speaks to
prophets this is nothing but a strong
okay so if so you're saying I want to
make sure I'm getting you you're saying
this is a a demon or the devil is that
is that fair those are the only two
possibilities you seem to think it could
be could be a demon or a fallen angel or
or or the Devil Himself yes I don't know
the difference between a fallen angel
and a demon but I that's that's fine
why then does the text repeatedly refer
to it as Samuel if if instead we're
supposed to know it's the
devil because it's the way that he came
because he named himself as Samuel
that's why but notice says when the
woman saw Samuel not when the woman saw
someone posing as Samuel and then it
says uh and Saul knew it was Samuel in
verse 14 it seems to go out of its way
in the text to stress this is really
Samuel why would the biblical author do
that if we're supposed to know and Saul
falsely thought it was Samuel but it
wasn't like why does the bible tells it
is Samuel if it
isn't well first of off the the
knowledge is coming from Saul and Saul
was not in his right mind so I wouldn't
trust that and other by the way that
other trans the the word that's there
for new is also can to be
perceived okay what about in verse 15
when it says Samuel said to Saul or or
verse 16 it's just being consistent with
what the story is saying it's not saying
that it was actually him okay so it's
not really it does it doesn't mean that
it actually is Samuel got it um okay I
think I started to asking this question
I think we got cut off by time and I
hope that doesn't happen again uh we
there was that I sent you the link in
the in the chat in the SDA website it
says ancient philosophy is full of
references of the immortality of the
soul and then a little bit later it says
this part of Greek philosophy was able
to influence Christian Traditions as
well it is thought that this process of
belief infiltration started around the
third Century ad as platonic philosophy
popped up in Christian teachings about
the soul is that your own view that you
don't find belief in uh the immortality
of the Soul prior to the
200s I believe that yeah around the
second to third century is when this
this when this uh became popular adopted
because what about in ancient Jewish
belief before the time of Christ so I
don't know if you've got uh if you've
got like the RSV C
uh you can get the revised standard
version that has the books that aren't
in Protestant Bibles but if you pull up
wisdom chapter 3 maybe we could take a
look at that and you could you could see
how to harmonize
that sorry miles I'm making you uh kind
of the mediator of the
Pope um what did you want brought up is
there wisdom three if you can pull that
up you'll have to use like the rsvce
because it's not in this first off there
was no Christian back in those days uh
Joe number one okay so it's
yeah we're back in the pre-christian
time but if if the claim is that this
didn't enter
Christianity didn't you know because I
know you had so here's a thing too you
had you were on with miles's show about
eight months ago where both he led you
misled you to say and falsely say that
minute that Ellen White says that the
immortality of the Soul was invented by
the Catholic church he never once said
that there's not a single quote that
supports that and nor in history
supports it the immortality of the Soul
existed in Genesis 3 you shall not
surely die
that's when it started okay so you think
immortality
is that's in contrast to what God meant
when he said you will die which is
meaning you will not live forever you
will not have immortality
so is it fair to hang on we're about
turn out of time let me just ask the
question if I may in wisdom three is it
fair to say the text as presented right
there is teaching the immortality of the
Soul whether you agree or disagree with
it isn't this at least clear evidence of
a Jewish belief in immortality of the
Soul prior to the coming of Christ
I think there's also support of of
saying that there's conditional
immortality as well including ananus who
you like to quote he also believed in
conditional immortality he unfortunately
had the platonic idea of soul and body
unfortunately but he also
beli is only is not inherent by human
nature it's only a gift by God and that
gift is by God is on condition of
acceptance of Jesus Christ by faith
that's what the Bible
says all right gentlemen thank you for
the Lively discussion this was excellent
we are going to transition now into your
8 Minute closings Joe you will go first
on these and Matt will go second your
time will begin sir when you begin
speaking all right well first of all
thank you again uh to Matt thank you to
miles for kind of moderating this and I
I think it's been a helpful I I mean
honestly as someone who does not come
from an Adventist background it's been
helpful to me to kind of hear you know
because there's plenty of arguments you
hear in your mind you think how in the
world would someone answer that and then
you you kind of hear them we haven't
even done much more than really
scratching the surface of this you know
we talked a little bit about Holy
Saturday but you've got a passage that
Jesus very clearly says to the thief on
the cross today truly I say to you today
you'll be with me in Paradise Luke
23:43 and I know uh that the standard
Adventist response to that is oh he just
means well today I'll tell you but that
I don't think holds up with a with a
natural reading of the text and I think
as you saw in the cross examination to
make the Adventist reading of the text
work you have to assume that when it
says he's alive you have to rrate in the
spirit vers by the spirit you have to
retranslate in first Peter three what it
means that Christ is going to preach to
the souls in prison isn't actually in a
chronological sequence of what he's
talking about with the death and
resurrection of Christ he's actually
taking a several thousand year
digression back to the time of Noah I
think all of those things taken together
you'd have to say okay these are not
natural readings of the text you cannot
just say oh I'm just taking what the
Bible says and then take one after
another after another wild
reinterpretations of the biblical text
in ways that nobody's ever read them
until the 19th century at the dawn of
adventism those things are just kind of
these forced ways of making it fit the
biblical data as I say we really are
just scratching the surface with all
this you've already seen the witch of
indor repeatedly we told it's Samuel to
be an Adventist you have to say it's not
really Samuel because if it is and he
knows the future that shows he's
actually not like with his soul just
asleep he's actually conscious he's able
to know things he's even able to
prophesy about the future so we have to
say actually it was a demon scolding him
and telling the future accurately things
that demons aren't famously uh known for
doing or take any of the other passages
we didn't even have time to get to for
instance the souls under the altar in
the Book of Revelation uh that are
crying out for justice I guess we could
say maybe that's all just a metaphor
just like Lazarus and the rich man we
can wave away all of the explicit
Revelation about the nature of the
afterlife and say maybe it's all just an
image maybe it's all just non-literal
kind of language but we're still left
with some pretty core theological
problems you have Jesus at the moment of
his death saying father into thy hands
commit my spirit right like right after
telling the man he'll be with him today
in Paradise right before going to preach
to the spirits in prison all of that
points to a clear distinction between
soul and body a distinction between soul
and body that is referenced numerous
times throughout the New Testament for
instance the distinction between killing
the body and killing the soul so I would
say that on the basis of this the most
natural reading is to say there is an
actual distinction and
unlike the body which will naturally die
whether you're righteous or unrighteous
your body will die and but for an
incredible Miracle right you're going to
decay in the grave that is the nature of
a body that is not the nature of a
spirit and so taking the human soul in
the sense used of spirit in the same way
we understand other Spirits Angels
demons the Holy Spirit these are all
references to
sensient beings with intellect with will
that actually have personhood they're
not just immaterial breath they actually
even when the Holy Spirit is described
his breath we're also told that he
preaches he does all these things so
even the reference to the spirit as
breath for instance in John 3 doesn't
mean that the Holy Spirit isn't still
personal very clearly uh you have for
instance in Acts 1:16 when we're told
Brethren the scripture has to be
fulfilled which the Holy Spirit spoke
beforehand so the holy spirit is an asan
he's speaking and this is the nature of
spirit this isn't something coming from
Greek philosophy this isn't something
entering Christianity in the 200s this
is something coming from scripture
itself whether you accept or reject
books like wisdom uh and you have these
kind of passages in these books that
were accepted by many of the early
Christians and uh were clearly not
coming from Greek philosophy like wisdom
chapter 3 like second mbes 15 where you
see two those who previous been departed
speak to somebody in a dream and again
know the Future these things that look
for all the world to be very clear
indications that your soul survives
death now either in Union with God what
we call eternal life or it survives
death out of Union with God which we
call Eternal death notice if you
understand that you can harmonize all
the biblical evidence I haven't needed
to do any exegetical backflips I haven't
needed to say oh that word that
everybody translates this way you have
have to take it this other way I haven't
had to do any of those things throughout
this debate for the simple reason that
all I'm proclaiming here is the biblical
doctrine of the relationship of body and
soul and I'll concede as I did at the
outset I'll do it again that if all you
had was Genesis say or all you had was
just the Torah there might be some
confusion about that this is something
that is progressively revealed and you
see that even in Acts of the Apostles
we're told the Sadducees who only have
the first five books disagree about the
nature of the Resurrection with the
Pharisees who have more so we would
expect that once you look outside of
just Genesis 2:7 you're going to get a
fuller more complete picture of the
Union of body and soul and sure enough
we find just that so what happens when
you die bodily you go into the grave
spiritually if you're in Union with God
you go to be in Union with God if you're
not in Union with God you go to a place
of everlasting torment at the last day
you'll be reunited with your body
for eternal glory or Eternal punishment
every part of what I've just told you is
clearly laid out in scripture and we
don't have to do exegetical back flips
to get there so there's a lot of other
stuff I'd kind of hope to get through I
I worried we'd have too much time it
turned out we were just scratching the
surface but I'm once again thankful uh
for I think a good and thorough debate
although not as thorough as I'm sure we
both would like and yeah I guess I look
forward to reading your comments all
right God bless
guys all right thank you for that Joe
Matt your closing statement is up you
will have eight minutes uninterrupted to
close us out here your time will start
when you begin speaking sir all right
thank you again Joe for this uh really
important discussion uh on how your
understanding of the nature of men the
nature of the Soul um although we didn't
get too much detail into it we did go on
to these um exceptional passages um I do
believe that the Bible is consistent all
throughout uh both Old Testament through
the New Testament and I think that like
you said um there is a progressive
revelation but the progressive re
Revelation and I will quote you on that
and I appreciate you quoted that in the
beginning uh does not contradict the
previous
Revelation um so what we see in the
Bible from the beginning is going to be
consistent all throughout um in the very
beginning we know that immortality was
taken away uh from human beings God had
guarded kicked man out of the Garden of
Eden uh and specifically and explicitly
for the reason that he may live forever
when God said that man will die as a
result of eating the fruit he wasn't
talking about merely a spiritual death
and by the way we still haven't defined
that spiritual death is defined in the
Bible as just someone who's in sin
someone who's in active Disobedience
Rebellion against God which they were in
um the death that God was speaking about
was immortality the Bible says by the
way speaking on that which I don't
understand how anybody can be confused
as a believer in the Bible on
immortality that we are not naturally
Immortal that God Alone according to 1
Timothy 6 ver1 15 and 16 is Immortal you
and I are subject to death we are mortal
that's why Paul repeatedly says in 1
Corinthians 15 that this mortality must
put on immortality immortality is to be
sought according to Romans 2:7 it says
who those of us who by patience and
well-doing seek immortality that God
will give eternal life to those who do
that again Jesus Christ when he
abolished death he brought life and
immortality to light through the gospel
and the gospel was existing all the way
from Genesis until Revelation this is
the testimony of scripture this is the
biblical uh picture that we see is that
immortality is on condition on belief in
Jesus Christ and Faith through him in
his blood and what he's done for us and
throughout the Bible death is often
described metaphorically as asleep it is
consistent everywhere we didn't get to
go through all the different texts as
well that uh explained it but we can go
to and consider Ecclesiastes chapter 9
verse 5-6 which states for the living
know that they will die but the dead
know
nothing right the dead know nothing they
have no further reward and their name is
even forgotten their love their hate
their jealousy have long since vanished
if Souls continue beyond death then how
do you harmonize that there is no love
there is no hate there is no jealousy
right they never again will they have a
part in anything that happens under the
sun outside obviously of the
resurrection of Christ if their life is
hid with him again the unconscious state
of the Dead is clearly shown again and
we didn't go to these texts uh in John
11 where Jesus speaks about Lazarus we
mentioned that earlier in my opening
statement again Paul in 1 Thessalonians
4 verse 13 to 14 again uh all believing
all of the Believers all the apostles
believe that death was asleep and that
sleep would be awakened according to
Daniel 12 at the resurrection many
multitudes who sleep in the dust of the
earth will awake some to everlasting
life and others to shame and everlasting
contempt so again this consistent
imagery throughout
scripture conas both the nature of death
and the hope that is beyond it which is
the resurrection that is the connection
uh we don't go into an intermediate
state where we await either you know uh
eternally burning forever and ever which
the Bible does not support there are
many places in Scripture that talk about
the destiny of the wicked in Psalms and
uh and every and other plac in the Old
Testament Malachi and job um you know
the wicked are going to be consumed
they're going to be no more they're
going to vanish like smoke they're going
to be destroyed and cut off there is no
natural immortality eternal life is
given to the righteous eternal life is
given to the obedient eternal life is
given to those who given their lives to
Christ who've accepted him the unsaved
won't get the benefit of eternal life
even if that means in punishing in
punishing um again we go into uh other
New Testament texts um again that
clearly portray this idea of a
resurrection in order to have life John
chap 5 verse 28- 29 do not be amazed at
this for a time is coming when all who
are in their graves this is not just
talking about bodies will hear his voice
and come out if the soul is the part
that animates the body of which I
believe job purports then how do you
harmonize the fact that they don't
praise the Lord in the grave the soul is
the part that supposedly is the one that
animates the human body and the body is
just a shell for the soul then how is it
that they're hearing the voice where
they if they're hearing his voice aren't
they with him already no they're hearing
their voice where from the grave and
they will come out Jesus Will awaken all
the Believers with his voice at that
time when he comes back again this
promise of Awakening
affirms that death is asleep from which
Christ himself will awaken his people in
conclusion scripture uh consistently
portrays this death is asleep it's an
unconscious temporary State until the
resurrection at Christ's return uh this
understanding magnifies the hope that we
have in Jesus who conquered death and
offers eternal life to all who believe
in him um again there are many other
texts that we could have went through
and many discussions we can have there's
many different angles on this but it is
clear once again that the Bible
metaphorically puts death as asleep
awaiting the resurrection and that is
how the Bible and both Old Testament and
New Testament both describe it in equal
parts um the texts that seemingly to be
contradictory are not real
contradictions or counterarguments at
all I think they're just Mis understood
because we're believing something when
we're coming into the text we have this
idea already so we read these things
into the text without carefully looking
at the context or the original intent of
where um uh of which they're laid so
I hope this was a great discussion for
everybody listening um I know that uh
you know time uh escapes us and during
the Q&A there's been a lot of
conversation and a lot of uh but I'm
looking forward to seeing the comments
and I'm looking forward to answering any
of the questions after and Joe it was a
pleasure uh to discuss with you miles
thank you so much for the platform um
maybe we'll do this again we'll
see all right and that will close things
out excellent debate G I greatly
appreciate the willingness of both of
you to come on and discuss and may
Christ richly uh bless all of you the
viewers in the grace and peace won by
him and his vicarious death on the cross
for Sinners until next time God bless
[Music]